[Musica]
[Applauso]
oltre al confine potrebbe essere il
titolo della mia vita
sono nata in una famiglia un po
multiculturale con due genitori che
venivano da due ambienti molto diversi
ma che si volevano molto bene e che
amavano molto la natura e quindi hanno
deciso di trasferirsi in valle d'aosta e
io sono cresciuta in un ambiente molto
protetto tra queste montagne bellissime
però possono mai stata considerata come
una di qui
voi che rispondete alla domanda di dove
vieni
se non dite niente siamo simili perché
io quando ero bambina avevo molta paura
di questa domanda preferiva non
rispondere perché una risposta sincera
avrebbe richiesto la spiegazione lunga e
personale e quindi
preferiva non dire niente
e invidiavo molto i bambini che invece
erano di qui da dieci generazioni perché
avevano una risposta chiara e perché
avevano identità ben definita
forse per questo che 12 anni fa appena
ho potuto ho valicato il confine
sono partita per gli stati uniti e ho
studiato lavorato o vissuto in otto
paesi diversi
su tre continenti diversi da quel
momento è la ragione di tutto questo
girovagare che ho intrapreso una
carriera accademica e sono diventata una
ricercatrice e poi una docente
universitaria in diritti umani ecco i
diritti umani
mi portano sempre a parlare delle
identità perché i diritti umani se si
possono spiegare in parole molto
semplici ci spiegano tutto quello che ci
unisce in quanto esseri umani che
abbiamo in comune
ma anche che ogni essere umano e unico
hanno un elemento di grande
individualismo irripetibile e quindi ci
spiegano quello che ci divide dalle
nostre differenze culturali religiose
tradizione le nostre diverse tradizioni
spiegarvi questo concetto utilizzo due
figure e scusatemi perché i disegni di
ho fatte io quindi insomma lascia un po
desidera comunque la prima è un
girotondo e questo utilizzo questo
questo simbolo perché in qualsiasi
cultura andiamo nel mondo proviamo
sempre i bambini che giocano girotondo e
quindi un simbolo di quello che abbiamo
in comune come esseri umani qualcosa che
è in un certo senso innato in tutte le
culture
invece per spiegarvi la diversità ho
scelto questa
figura ovviamente sono persone diverse
che vengono tradizioni diverse religioni
diverse diversi fisionomie e che parlano
lingue diverse e ho scelto tutte le
lingue non latine proprio per spiegare
questa questa diversità ecco diciamo che
studiando i diritti umani mi sono un po
illusa mi sono illusa che alla domanda
di dove sei
io potessi rispondere sono la cittadina
del mondo
però se qualcuno di voi italiano è
andato a vivere all'estero sa che basta
pochissimo per
sentirsi italiani subito
insomma ci si chiamano subito in poche
parole e io avrei potrebbe raccontare
fare un libro di aneddoti comunque non
racconterò uno solo è la prima volta che
sono andata davvero lontano da casa
ero a san francisco e veroli a studiare
ea un certo punto ho deciso di farmi una
torta quindi avevo la mia ricetta con
gli ingredienti ecc vado al supermercato
per scoprire che non riesco a comprare
nulla a capirla con una quantità perché
tutte le quantità che io avevo in g
lì sono in caps e tis phone
dopo un pomeriggio dopo ho capito sta la
conversione detto ahmad manca l'italia
ecco molto presto mi son sentita anche
molto valdostana perché mancavano le
montagne e e direi che
è
direi che a un certo punto quando
qualcuno mi ha chiesto di dove sei
dall'altra parte del mondo
ho risposto naturalmente senza nessun
problema sono italiana primo da una
bellissima regione alle pendici del
monte bianco che si chiama valle d'aosta
la distanza a volte aiuta a ritrovare
noi stessi
però il problema dell'identità non è un
problema solo mio e non è un problema
solo di chi viene da una famiglia
multiculturale un po diverso dagli altri
un problema di tutti e penso che sia un
problema soprattutto chi è di qui da
dieci generazioni a causa della
globalizzazione
perché la globalizzazione ci ha messo
davanti a questo problema identitario a
quello che ci unisce tutti gli altri
esseri umani e quello che ci divide
ecco è per questo che è diventato
davvero il tema fondamentale delle mie
ricerche che si concentrano su gli
effetti che la globalizzazione ha sui
diritti umani
ecco che senso l'identità in un mondo
globalizzato
io me lo sono chiesto tante volte e
diciamo che per spiegarlo qui nel poco
tempo che abbiamo faccio un esempio
immaginate se sostituissimo a tutta
questa diversità queste lingue così
diverse tra loro e lo in inglese
sarebbe una cosa negativa positiva
potrebbe dire molto positivo ovviamente
molto positivo perché queste persone che
sono così diverse tra loro che parlano
idiomi così diversi neanche lo stesso
alfabeto riescono a comunicare magari si
troveranno in disaccordo su alcune cose
è d'accordo su altre avranno una lingua
in comune però se eliminassimo questa
diversità
per l'inglese
perderemo anche qualcosa di unico che
tutte queste lingue ci danno proveremo
qualcosa che rappresenta questa
diversità
ecco le mie ricerche si sono concentrate
molto sulla sezione diritti umani
e infatti
la globalizzazione ha da un lato creato
opportunità di scambi e interazioni mai
visti prima
facendoci sognare di essere tutti parte
di un mondo unito ma dall'altro ha
rivelato tutte le disuguaglianze
il sistema produttivo profondamente
ingiusto
questione identitaria investe anche il
tema della sostenibilità che è quello di
cui parla oggi la giornata verde e
spesso presentata come un progetto
progressista è rivolto alla salvaguardia
del nostro pianeta per le generazioni
future
ed è anche spesso connessa
all'avanzamento tecnologico industriale
ecco portate questa immagine queste
pagine è la cover dan è una diga e una
centrale idroelettrica costruita negli
anni 30 negli stati uniti
pensate a quasi cent'anni e tutor a
fornisce energia pulita a più di un
milione di persone al mondo e
sicuramente un miracolo ingegneristico e
tecnologico
che però trasmette anche l'imponenza
dell'impatto ambientale che l'uomo sulla
natura anche se si tratta di fonti
rinnovabili
per me la foto emblematica
dell'approccio che l'uomo spesso nei
confronti della natura lo sfruttamento
di risorse naturali mediante tecnologia
all'avanguardia
forse per questa ragione continuiamo
anche i giorni nostri a connettere
l'ecologia al progresso e alla
tecnologia e al futuro ecco il risultato
di questa narrazione e che in molti
contesti politici sono soprattutto le
città a votare in favore di partiti
ecologisti o conoscendo ecologista
invece le campagne tendono a preferire
partiti conservatori che spesso non
inseriscono tra le loro priorità la
sostenibilità ambientale
ma al contrario in alcuni contesti
politici la considerano addirittura una
farsa
parlando del cambiamento climatico come
di un problema inesistente o comunque
non dipendente dall'attività dell'uomo
nelle zone rurali del mondo dove la
sopravvivenza di ogni attività
produttiva turistica e che la vita
stessa dipendono dalla questione
ambientali le persone sembrano
apparentemente non interessarsi al
problema ma perché
ecco io credo che le ragioni profonde di
questo distaccamento dall'ecologia
derivino dalla questione identitaria
infatti alcuni studi identificano come
una delle ragioni del disinteresse per
il cambiamento climatico
il fatto che spesso le popolazioni
rurali non si sentano sufficientemente
incluse nella gente ambientalista io
penso che l'apporto delle tradizioni
rurali al progetto di conservazione del
nostro pianeta sia stato e sia tuttora
sottovalutato l'ecologia è percepita
come futuro progresso tecnologia non
passate tradizioni ecco io ritengo
invece che bisognerebbe prendere
ricordare che sostenibilità non
significa solo costruire centrali
idroelettriche ma anche conservare la
nostra natura selvaggia incontaminata
per quello che è qui alcune immagini di
natura selvaggia e incontaminata
che riusciamo a conservare su questo
pianeta la prima viene da un'isola
nell'oceano pacifico
dove l'uomo non mette piede e in cui
dei volatili stupendi
nidificano la seconda viene dalla
namibia tale terzo nella media
e un altro luogo dove l'uomo non è molto
presente terzo è un parco naturale sobel
in botswana
dove gli elefanti sono diciamo i re di
questo parco è poi visto che siamo
capaci anche noi anche qua ti protegge
la nostra fauna questa viene dal parco
del gran paradiso
ecco
non a caso il termine sostenibilità in
francese giocabilità si riferisce a un
mondo che dura nel tempo le popolazioni
che vivono una vita tra le più
sostenibili sono le popolazioni indigene
che normalmente hanno una cultura
tradizionale i nostri nonni riprovare
una vita più sostenibile della nostra
perché comprare locale e coltivare gli
ortaggi in maniera naturale ma come si
dice oggi biologica
sono le basi di un'economia sostenibile
insomma la sostenibilità è in parte
sinonimo della mantenimento e
rafforzamento di tradizioni rurali
millenarie che hanno conservato al
nostro pianeta per secoli gli abitanti
di queste aree del mondo possono
apportare un contributo decisivo alla
conservazione del pianeta vi faccio
degli esempi concreti nel 2019 forse vi
ricorderete
l'australia ha dovuto affrontare una
delle crisi ambientale più grande per il
verificarsi di una serie di incendi
devastanti oggi molte ricerche
dimostrano che la prevenzione degli
incendi in australia potrebbe essere
attuata almeno in parte attraverso delle
tecniche utilizzate dagli aborigeni
australiani che sono state erroneamente
e progressivamente abbandonata nel tempo
un altro esempio
siamo nel bel mezzo di una crisi del
suolo
numerose ricerche dimostrano come il
suolo della terra abbia perso gran parte
del proprio notiziare potenziale
nutritivo e questo potrebbe portare dei
problemi di malta operazione per
tantissime della popolazione mondiale
questo impoverimento che a lungo andare
porta alla desertificazione
ovviamente possiamo già vedere in grande
parte del globo avviene principalmente
perché l'agricoltura e l'allevamento
intensivo limitano il materiale organico
che normalmente piante animali riversano
nel suolo questa crisi potrebbe essere
evitata ritornando almeno in parte
all'utilizzo di tecniche di agricoltura
e allevamento tradizionali che per
esempio permettono agli animali di
rilasciare naturalmente sostanza
organica nel suolo due immagini che a me
piacciono tantissimo di animali che sono
ben felici di
immergersi nel suolo e sembra veramente
incredibile ma è questo che mantiene il
ciclo della vita e la soluzione sembra
essere anche in questo caso un ritorno a
ciò che facevano i nostri nonni nel
coltivare la terra e allevare gli
animali
ecco io penso che una delle sfide
comunicative più importanti del nostro
secolo sia quella di coinvolgere ogni
persona al mondo nella lotta contro il
cambiamento climatico
le innovazioni tecnologiche
che verranno applicate in futuro saranno
sicuramente di grande supporto
ma non saranno sufficienti a salvare il
mondo da una catastrofe ambientale il
pianeta una possibilità di farcela solo
se tutti noi apportiamo un contributo
alla sua salvezza
per questo è fondamentale imparare gli
uni dagli altri
al di là di ogni divisione ideologica
perché la sfida che abbiamo davanti è la
salvaguardia della vita sulla terra
non c'è sfida più importante è non può
essere vinta se capito affrontata solo
da alcuni deve essere sentita e
abbracciato da tutti
ecco è su questa nota io vorrei evitare
ognuno di voi quando uscite da qua a
pensare a quale può essere il vostro
contributo per la sostenibilità
ovviamente se siete degli ingegneri se
lavorate sui pannelli solari fantastico
strada vento una critica a chi fa questo
tipo di lavoro e nell'innovazione
ma se siete anche degli agricoltori se
siete degli allevatori salvati in un
supermercato e vedete come la produzione
funziona beh sicuramente avete delle
conoscenze che possono portarci un passo
avanti perché non so voi ma io proprio
non riesco a pensare che secondo alcune
stime tra cent'anni se continuiamo così
ci ritroveremo senza più i coralli nel
male e senza fioranese sole anni sulle
alpi ecco quando ho preparato
questo discorso operato queste foto dove
probabilmente che mi rendono entrambe
tristi troppe le due regioni diverse la
prima i coralli del mare questa è una
foto viene dalla polinesia ovviamente
sono corali stupendi e rarissimi
ecco quando guardo questa foto
penso che sono triste perché se questi
coralli non esisteranno più
perderemo un patrimonio dell'umanità
mi sento connessa a questi coralli
perché sento che fanno parte di un ciclo
della vita di cui facciamo tutti parte e
perderli vorrebbe dire non riuscire a
proteggere questa parte così importante
così bella del nostro pianeta quando
guardo la seconda immagine invece che è
un lago della val veny proprio qua
vicino
qui è diverso la tristezza che sento è
una tristezza sulla mia identità perché
penso che se quel lago non esiste più
perderò una parte di me perché io quella
l'ho visto quando era una bambina pieno
d'acqua bianca e perderlo vuol dire
perdere una parte di chi sono
ecco allora
io penso che
se noi io ho pensato che la natura è
meravigliosa perché ci dà la possibilità
di connettere la nostra umanità con la
nostra identità
ecco perché quando diciamo per tornare
alla domanda iniziale
io sono di qua noi ci identifichiamo con
un territorio quel territorio fa parte
della nostra identità
pensavo a quale territorio identifica e
ho trovato questa foto perché il mio
identifica davvero perché è stata presa
nella prima casa dove ha abitato quando
era una bambina da giardino e quindi
penso che questa sia casa
allo stesso tempo la natura ha anche il
potere di
connetterci con tutti gli altri esseri
umani e con tutti gli altri essere
viventi ma per questa non ho una slide
ma una dimostrazione pratica e rim ei
guerrieri ei qua
ecco questa bellezza assoluta
io l'ho preso al canile quattro anni fa
questo cane e da quando è con me penso
tutti i giorni a quante cose abbiamo in
comune presenta se dobbiamo metterci a
dieta siamo tristissimi tutti e due ecco
io penso che se riuscissimo a sfruttare
questa meraviglia della natura per
connetterci e per trovare una sintesi
tra la nostra identità e la nostra
umanità non solo riusciremo ad
affrontare le sfide per il futuro ma
anche a creare una società molto
migliore vi lascio con un sogno che ho
una speranza per il futuro io spero che
tra cent'anni i miei bisnipoti ni
potranno camminare una star e all'altra
valle qui vicino sempre sotto il monte
bianco
e giocare con la neve come ho giocato io
quand'ero bambina che ci sia tanta neve
che ci siano dei ghiacciai bianchi non
riesco a pensare a un sogno nello stesso
tempo più sostenibile e identitario no
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]